on m'avait dit va à 7
la saint jean
ce jour là les hommes et règles de vieux
comptes et ce n'est pas une plaisanterie
[Applaudissements]
un tournoi d'hommes je me suis laissé
tenter
[Applaudissements]
sur le grand canal de cet entre deux
ponts on a dressé une arène on l'appelle
le cadre royal c'est la chorale yeux le
plus incroyable des tournois aurélien
evangelisti a accepté que le montions
sur sa barque sa stature et son charisme
m'impressionne les joutes sétoises
aurélien il en a fait sa vie depuis tout
petit et ici on le surnomme le patron
l'année dernière encore il a terrassé
tous ses adversaires
[Applaudissements]
six fois il a remporté le titre
les joutes font partie de nos propres de
notre patrimoine de notre adn à cette
gagner cette série c'est tout joueur
c'est entrer au panthéon des jeux c'est
devenir immortel donc voilà lance des
joutes de mettre 80 de long avec au bout
de la lance qu'on appelle nous il est
pur c'est un tube qui est coupée avec
trois dames malheureusement quand ça
quand ça rappe ça peut faire très mal
des jouteurs que l'on reçue dans le
visage ils ont eu des fois jusqu'à 50
points de suture voilà le le pavois du
jouteur il pèse environ 8 kg la surface
de frappe c'est qu'ici tout le reste est
prohibé et c'est une arme des facile
mais ça peut être aussi une arme
offensive
[Musique]
quand on vous appelle que c'est votre
tour que vous montez les marches de la
bigue et que vous prenez place sur la
tête m voilà là c'est c'est très prenant
et c'est des moments où justement c'est
là où il faut être fort
psychologiquement pour pas traquer
puisque chaque fois contre moi on rêve
d'accrocher le scalp on va dire aux à
son tableau de chasse
il n'y a pas de place pour les femmes
aujourd'hui c'est une histoire de l
affaire est très sérieuse il est un
protocole à suivre c'est toujours le
même depuis le premier tournoi en l'an
de grâce 1666 germinal rossa et le
commentateur attitré des joutes un rôle
très important
c'est lui qui doit faire respecter les
règles les jeunes et laura tant il
semble que la saint louis soit beaucoup
plus qu'une simple fête annuelle
c'est en fait une guérilla très ancienne
qui perdu entre des villes voisines à
chaque ville son seigneur un seul sera
proclamé roi avec pour seule gloire son
nom gravé sur un pavois en bois exposé
au musée de la ville
bamoro gagner c'est du devoir limiter à
notre secteur mais qui est une au board
ça s'explique pas ça brio ce matin en
croisant les barreurs des deux barques
élit un moment d'émotion particulier
louis molle et andré lubrano me confie
que c'est leur dernière sein du vieux
couple de même de 3 ha il se retire sur
la pointe des pieds
je pense que la vraie démocratie affirme
ce soir là que débarque au ras
teura les barques
d'écolo et du jeune homme qui préfère un
petit pincement au coeur
[Musique]
l'armure
[Applaudissements]
oh
ils paradent fièrement les jouteurs de
béziers de frontignan de palavas et tous
les autres il ne manque qu'un le sétois
aurélien evangelisti se méfie de
l'esprit festif de la foule
il se cache là quelque part il faut le
voir pour le croire
dix mille personnes le cadre royal est
bondé
[Applaudissements]
il est 14 heures et tout va se jouer en
une après-midi l'ambiance est électrique
[Applaudissements]
aurélien se faufile au dernier moment il
ne souhaite parler à personne et s'isole
dans les gradins en attendant son tour
[Applaudissements]
c'est un bon jour
nous embarquons avec landry sur la
barque rouge
l'un touchant chaîne très vite fait
partie est salée
tracy surtout pas fatigué dès la mort
dans l'âme et capoue center et loi ils
apprennent découdront pour essayer de
papier c'est obligé dans leur barreur de
l'areuse obtenir ce poste durable vas-y
non
où il rentrait moi aussi voir le champ
voilà notre but c'est d'amener les
chanteurs qui font des sauts en fait ce
qu'on appelle être en ligne c'est à dire
il faut que l'argent soit vraiment dans
la tête j'allais rater les filles
[Applaudissements]
et
et quartier rouge et a possédé vous
écartez vous locaux la halle est un
maître le moigne
essayez là j'avais fait une grosse
claque s'amuse dalo on peut pas les
interdire c'est lorsqu'elle nous ne
sommes qu'au début du tournoi et rené
castaldo anciens jouteurs c'est que la
journée va être longue
tirer au sort les jouteurs embarque soit
sur la barque rouge soit sur la bleue
perché au sommet de la tintaine à plus
de trois mètres au dessus de l'eau les
97 concurrents vont enchaîner les passes
un jouteur doit faire tomber trois
adversaires pour accéder aux finales
autant d'appréhension que j'ai bien
qu'ils veulent et les biquettes bien
tout cela milovan travail il impose la
trouille
c'est pas du trac c'est de la trouille
[Applaudissements]
alors là il arriva
trois longues heures d'affrontements
déjà sur la barque rouge aurélien et
maintenant tout près de moi j'observe et
voit ses adversaires tomber un à un
et sur la barque toujours les mêmes
rameurs à la fin du tournoi ils auront
plus de 12 km dans les bras alors ma
réalité d'alors
la fatigue c'est un trop dur
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est en partie grecque place voilà
aurélien evangelisti comme tout champion
ses adversaires cherchent à le
déstabiliser
mais ils ne montrent rien c'est le
patron il écoute il ajouté mais des
jouteurs y arrive quand même passé il y
en a aussi qui ont une
s'ils n'ont pas le poids et de force
physique sont beaucoup plus athlétique
et arrivent à leur sujet
[Musique]
aurélien est adulé ou détesté ils
semblent nombreux ceux qui aimeraient le
voir tomber et certains ne ménagent pas
leurs critiques
[Applaudissements]
il regardera tout le monde y faire
regardez le coin et métis
[Musique]
c'est vous dire
[Applaudissements]
à
si tu tombes sur un gay matière
sur le plancher des foules
réponse et cela me semble dérisoire
il faut pourtant un sacré courage pour
imaginer vaincre hors éléments
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
aurélien engine 3 et se qualifie pour
les finales
c'est vrai que je mettrai jamais ça
serait bien
[Musique]
valentin et sur la barque rouge pour
accrocher le nom de chaque jouteur en
lice sur la plaque traditionnel sylla
cette place privilégiée c'est parce
qu'il joue tu lui aussi chez les jeunes
la joute à 7 c'est une histoire de
famille voici le père de valentin qui
monte sur la tintaine et dans la famille
fabre le grand père ancien jouteurs bien
sûr tremble pendant le combat
[Applaudissements]
ça fait chaque année on a toujours la
chair de poule
que gagne un petit peu alors que je
tourne avec thomas des livres
regard de braise
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
regardez
les deux hommes sont à l'eau on devrait
rajouter la passe mais le jury estime
que le point est bon et sébastien fabre
est éliminé
[Applaudissements]
voilà voilà
il vaut mieux sauter en janvier avec un
passé si au lieu
j'avais de l'argent mais il y avait des
bons pour la courage et bonne route
18h et ce soleil qui n'en finit plus de
cogner
les foyers commentaire
les frontignanais surnommés les ventres
bleus ont de vieilles rancunes le port
de sète a été construit sur les terres
de frontignan
il faut ranger la france alors ils ont
leur seigneur claude massias est le seul
à pouvoir reprendre le bouclier à
aurélien evangelisti et le ramener en
territoire frontignanais
[Musique]
je me prends au jeu c'est qu'on va tout
en force et d'une rare beauté me fascine
finalement c'est un sétois qui viendra à
bout de macias
le grand canal est libre pour aurélien
alors que je m'attendais au roulement de
tambour un champ s'élèvent seller de
l'hommage au barreur louis andré vont
mener maintenant leur dernière barque de
jouteurs il y est qu'ils m'appellent
là est le maintien
il est 21h c'est la joute finale
montel un agathois se retrouve face à
aurélien normalement mon tél
il aime pas trop il dira pas il n'y aura
pas resté là trop peur il va lisser le
tester pour voir en pot il va se donner
beaucoup il va le tester
et si jamais le cas est passé il va être
testé dans l'eau
[Applaudissements]
cette fois invincible cette fois de 7
qui l'aurait cru le monde était un peu
vite à la folie prendre à toute heure
tant que ce sera possible
[Musique]
c'était une histoire de guerrier et si
heureusement la mort n'est plus au bout
de la lance pour l'honneur du bouclier
ses hommes auront combattu jusqu'à la
nuit
le cadre royal se vide
je reste étourdi fasciné par ces joutes
qui loin du folklore mort ont donné les
frissons d'un vrai combat
[Musique]